is a Hall of Fame baseball player and
one of the bests in our profession of
sports broadcasting when he's behind the
mic with Joe Bakken when you see him on
MLB network's programming as well but
for the moment he is just joining us as
a member of the field of the u.s. Senior
Open he is none other than John Smoltz
how are you John that is so weird to
hear and I'm uh I'm numb I'll be honest
I'm sitting here on the driving range
thinking about how could this how do we
find a way to play a few more days after
after Friday so walk me through how you
qualified for this when and now yes
those you know I had a is in the middle
of a pretty good work schedule I had
basically in a thirty day span had only
been home about four days and so I flew
home to play in this qualifier and had
high expectations but just whenever you
get there I just try to figure out if I
could play kind of golf on a play and I
left my house at 5:15 in the morning i
teed off first shot a 69 birdie in 15 16
and 17 and then had to wait eight hours
and found out I was in a playoff
three-way playoff for one spot after
eight hours so hitting balls at the
seven hour and thirty mark was not a
pewter saw it you just said okay just
get back in your car and go home I just
I I got into a situation where my car
just what was the closest thing I could
remember to pitching is just remember
being tired and just try to throw one
pitch at a time and in the playoff I
tried to hit one shot at a time and did
that relatively well the first five
shots and then it got really hectic
after that birdied the first hole
eliminated one guy another guy birdied
so I was two guys for one spot we went
two holes we played a couple ugly shots
and ultimately I was afforded you know
you play match play at that point you
don't really care what your score is
okay I made a mistake on 18 after he
made a mistake to get back level and but
luckily a two-butted and he did not
hmm so what it's all said and done John
you qualified for this by shooting a
score waiting eight hours to find out if
that score was good enough found out
that it wasn't you needed to play in a
playoff and then what was the score that
you you went on with again technically
so yeah so I I went we both went birdie
on the first so we both bogey the second
hole and then I doubled because he hit
his ball in the water off the tee and it
laid left me with two shot bandits and I
made a critical mistake that I'll never
make again instead of playing it safe
out of the bunker I tried to hit it to
the green and knowing that if I did that
it would there's no way he could tie me
and I brought a tie back into play by
hitting the lip of the bunker and
hitting it in the water so I had a
really good shot after my emotions if
you can only imagine what that was
learning after sinking to a ball in the
water
I hit it to about ten feet and he hit it
to about 20 feet so you know I had the
easier putt just missed it and he just
missed his comeback they're coming back
unbelievable
John Smoltz here on the Rich Eisen show
how does this compare to the to the
butterflies or nerves that you you felt
at any point any point during your Major
League Baseball Hall of Fame career
John so the only way I could compare is
my last game that I do I was going to
pitch for the Cardinals I came out out
of the pen in the playoffs couldn't spit
couldn't whistle had my stomach was in
knots um never felt that my entire
career never felt that in any playoff
game I guess the only way I could think
about that you know I knew that this was
it you know this was going to be it and
this Trump's at ten times over this is
uh I was confident in my sport baseball
I had all the pitches I wanted even
though I was limited with st. Louis at
the end I felt like I still could
compete in golf I have you know
three-quarters of what you need and I
hope to avoid that other quarter you
know that shot where you don't feel
comfortable or you're not as
competent and the baseball from a team
concept everything I did had a team
oriented concept you know when the World
Series together we can't win the Scion
by yourself in golf it's all you you
don't hide you can't tap somebody else
come pick the shot so there's definitely
a anxiousness on nerves that I've never
felt in baseball you know if there's
certain areas of the golf course I've
been to Michael oh now what so that's
that's the part I'm trying to learn each
moment I play in a tournament
I learned something usually it's
creating but that's okay
I learned lesson and I go from there and
the biggest thing that I'm trying to do
is swing with with freedom instead of
protection or defense because the golf
course like this as tough as it is can
make you be very defensive and I don't
want to do that the golf course like
this being the Broadmoor East course in
Colorado Springs Colorado from where
John Smoltz is calling before practice
round of the u.s. Senior Open that he
qualified for hold on a minute after
waiting eight hours to see if he needed
to play in a playoff and did and then
eventually qualified with a double bogey
in match play I got that right right
John that's all accurate from yeah
unbelievable so how what was your
reaction when you found out that you I
mean we just showed a photograph of you
holding up the card that made it
official how did you sell it yeah if you
will I am so leave my house at five
o'clock in the morning hmm and on my way
back about an hour forty I get on the
car and I called my wife nobody because
everyone knew I was in a playoff but
then I didn't talk to anybody for now in
45 minutes that's all I she took yeah
they pretty much assumed that I had lost
and you know when I called I just
started screaming and she I said I made
it I screamed like a little
five-year-old and then my second call
was to Joe Buck I told him three years
ago that I was going to meet the Senior
Tour some point he was going to call it
because Fox has it so I started
screaming to Joe Buck there's nothing to
describe it it's not anything I've done
individually in a baseball field where I
felt this kind of emotion maybe in
Houston after pitching three innings
relief
to Game five I gave that kind of double
fist pump screaming on the mound it's
the only time you'll see that kind of
emotion but this was this was
unbelievable
and is it true that you were speaking of
Joe Buck back in a booth with him
shortly thereafter your your
qualification round John yeah yeah we go
so my schedule hasn't slowed down as
soon as this is over I fly to the
network I'm next week I fly to LA work
Saturday mm-hmm take the red-eye home
three days later I fly back out for the
American Century
take them head to the all-star game call
the all-star game and if I'm still
walking Wednesday I fly home it's
unbelievable man and so who have you
seen I guess on the practice tee or out
and about yeah that you have seen it
you're not competing with here John
yeah there's been the coolest part I
mean I've gotta be friends with a few of
the guys here on tour all of them just
like generally super happy for me
playing with Freddy couples and Lee
Janzen here about 15 hurts I just feel
like you know the only way I can explain
to people to go to fantasy camp baseball
camp for that week they you know that's
what I feel like I'm in vanished camp
but I'm trying to compete and I'm trying
to to get to the you know cut line or
thereabout sure see what happens there's
a lot of anticipation a lot of people
have been unreal here in Colorado last
time I was here I was reminded that I
won a game in April of 2007 so I I enjoy
hitting a golf ball more than I do
throwing a baseball
since this rarefied air you know and and
so hey look I mean so you won the last
time you're in Colorado I can't you make
it two in a row John let's be honest we
will be playing for days how about that
and I'm just I am tickled to death that
tremendous respect for the guys on this
tour for what they've done their whole
career and I did make this a dream of
mine I did say when I was part of
someday playing on the Senior Tour I've
achieved it and it won't be the last
that's awesome so you got Jansen and
couples in a practice round who are you
slated to tee off would play the actual
tournament events over Thursday morning
that real early which is good because I
don't like to wait right
it'll be Bob Ford and Jim and Jim and I
know Bob real well from Seminole and
Oakmont and it should be a fun pairing
and it should be a fun working on to to
settle the nerves because there will be
some yes a little the first hole the
practice round I'm very calm I'm pretty
confident with my t-ball I'm confident
that I know where it's going 95% of the
time but the alley to shoot through the
first tee there were a lot of confident
people lined up thinking that I was
definitely going to get it straight so
that was that was a fun bowl of visual
everything you've said to this point I
honestly don't know how it feels because
I've never played baseball to see
obviously your Hall of Fame level or any
level close to it golf the same way but
when I play any in any charity celebrity
golf tournaments and people are just
standing by the the tea or the green
like they think I'm actually a good
player yeah it was it was uh it felt
good to hit you know in a practice round
everything's much more relaxing I got
you know how many no-hitters I've thrown
in the bullpen I told people I know when
you cross the white line that you need
that best uh best stuff so that's what
I'm hoping for tomorrow like I said
early round will be good for me and get
out there and it's gonna be hot so
playing early will help Friday I think
it's gonna be close to 96 97 degrees so
that's usually not temperatures in this
area so it'd be interesting well John
you're you're you're on a courtesy also
of MLB Network so I'm mandated to say
tonight's angels and Red Sox Friday
Yankees and Red Sox and those are events
that you will not be part of because you
will be in Colorado hopefully qualifying
for the weekend and I look forward to
seeing that John well thanks a lot for
having me of course anytime John good
luck him
straight you got it that is John Smoltz
from the tea box or I'd be pardon me the
practice range it sounded like in
Colorado Broadmoor East course in
Colorado Springs Colorado where tomorrow
he will be teeing off with Bob Ford and
Jim McGovern in round one of the u.s.
Senior Open the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience